- What's up Believe Nation?
So, we crossed 550,000
YouTube subscribers,
thank you for that.
I've made over 3,600 public videos
and over 4,000 videos total
if you include the
private and unlisted ones.
I often get asked by people
about the journey, about the climb.
People often think that
I'm not truly gifted
or talented at this because all they see
is where I'm at now as opposed
to where I was when I started.
So, I thought it'd be fun to go back
and look at the very first YouTube video
that I uploaded from April of 2009.
So, seven years ago, just to show you guys
how far I've come but also,
hopefully, serve as
inspiration for you guys.
The points are great, the story is good,
but, I'm super nervous, I'm sitting down.
I'm in a suit, I'm trying
to memorize my lines.
Thankfully, I partnered
up with one of my friends,
Mark Drager, who's actually in my book,
Your One Word around his
one word of extraordinary.
(rock music)
He helped me with some of the editing
and filming on that video
so it looks professional
but I was just terrible.
So, I thought you guys
would enjoy the look back.
I'm curious to hear what you think.
(upbeat music)
Hello and welcome to another edition
of Modeling the Masters.
My name is Evan Carmichael.
Today, we're going to be talking
about the famous entrepreneur Walt Disney
and how you can model his strategies
to achieve success with your business.
Everyone knows Walt Disney for his movies,
theme parks, and cast of characters.
What most people don't know
is when he first started out
he had no money, he had
to live in his office
because he couldn't afford
rent for an apartment.
He survived on a diet of cold beans
because he couldn't afford food.
By committing to his
business and sticking with it
he was now able to build a business
that has almost 40 billion
dollars in revenue.
Today, we're going to
look at three lessons
that you can learn from
Walt Disney's success
and apply it into your company.
Lesson number one is find
something that you love.
Walt Disney grew up in the early 1900s
on a farm in Missouri and
developed a passion for drawing.
So much so that one of his
neighbors actually paid him
to draw some cartoons of his horses.
When Walt Disney got to school he found
that he was a good student
but he really enjoyed
doodling as opposed to paying
attention to his teachers.
He connected with one of
his high school papers
and started drawing patriotic
cartoons for the school paper.
When he was 16, though,
he found that school
just wasn't for him.
So, he dropped out, joined the red cross,
learned to become an ambulance driver,
and actually was shipped to France
to become an ambulance driver over there.
He couldn't lose that passion
for drawing and cartooning
and he ended up plastering his ambulance
full of different cartoon
creations that he had made.
People knew him on the street
because he was the ambulance driver
with all the different cartoons
plastered on his ambulance.
He decided that cartooning was for him,
he was going to be an artist,
an he returned to America
to start his career as an artist.
So, lesson number one
really is make sure you have
that strong passion for your business.
If you don't really love it
it's going to be hard to
succeed as a business owner.
If you look at any famous entrepreneur
and why they started their business,
it wasn't for the money.
Money comes when you're really passionate
about what you're doing.
So, think about what is it
that you do in your spare time?
What do you really enjoy doing?
What gets you going in the morning?
What are your hobbies and
how can you turn those
into a potential business opportunity?
Lesson number two is push the boundaries.
Walt Disney first made his mark in 1934,
when he proposed making a
feature length animation
which had never been done before.
It was called Snow White.
It took him three years to make,
he went a hundred percent over budget,
people thought he was crazy for doing it,
he ran out of money at the end
and had to actually act out
the last scenes of the movie
for his bankers to get the money he needed
to close and finish the movie.
It ended up being a huge success.
It was the biggest hit of the year.
He won an Academy Award for it
and it was a financial gain for him.
Walt Disney's next big
project was Disneyland,
a 330 acre project out in California.
A theme park which had
nothing to do with his movies.
People thought he was crazy again.
"Why would you do this?
"What tie does it have
to your movie business?"
But he had a vision.
He was determined to make it happen.
And, again, it was a big success for him.
Then he went on to open
up the Walt Disney World
in Florida and the company
was able to open up
different theme parks around the world.
The message for entrepreneurs
here is push the boundaries.
You need to do something different
to get your company noticed.
As a small entrepreneur,
there's so much competition.
It's so difficult to get
on people's radar screens
and make them pay attention to you
so you have to do something
that's going to get you noticed.
Something that will help
you standout from the crowd.
What is it that will be your
equivalent of a Snow White?
Something that's never been done before
that's really going to get you noticed
and get the attention
paid to your business.
Lesson number three is stay top of mind.
Walt Disney did everything he could
to make sure people kept
remembering the Walt Disney name.
He did a lot of advertising as an example.
He did TV campaigns,
direct mail campaigns,
print ads, he even did
grocery store coupon cutouts.
So, when you're at the grocery store
you're thinking about Walt Disney.
He was also a pioneer in merchandising.
So, whenever a new feature film came out
that was a Walt Disney production,
you would also be able to
buy all the merchandise
that went along with it.
Today Walt Disney is known
not only for its movies
but its TV stations, theme parks, dolls,
toys, games, and a whole
host of other merchandise.
So, the lesson for entrepreneurs
is stay top of mind.
You need to do whatever you can
to make sure your customers
are always thinking about you.
The easiest way to grow a business
is to sell more to your
existing customers.
The hardest way to grow a business
is to go out and try
to find new customers.
Do whatever you can to
make sure your customers
are always thinking about you,
you're the first person that comes to mind
when they're thinking about
your product or service
and it's the best way to be
able to grow your business.
Walt Disney is an entrepreneurial legend
who's built up one of the
most recognized companies
in the world.
But remember, when he first got started
he had no money, nobody believed in him,
he had to live out of his office
because he couldn't afford an apartment.
He survived on a diet of cold beans
because he couldn't afford other food.
By following his lessons, though,
you, too, can achieve
entrepreneurial success.
So, remember, find something you love,
push the boundaries, and stay top of mind.
I hope you've enjoyed this
episode of Modeling the Masters.
To learn more about Walt Disney
and his entrepreneurial success,
you can visit our website
at EvanCarmichael.com
and you can also check out our
blog which is listed below.
I also want to take this opportunity
to thank Phanta Media for
the great work they've done
in producing this video.
I hope you'll join us for the next episode
of Modeling the Masters.
(easy listening music)
(upbeat music)
So, thank you guys so much for watching.
That is, uh, embarrassing to watch.
Every time I look at that video like,
oh, it's so bad, I should
take that video down.
But the points are still good and I think
that it helps show the
climb and the journey.
If you follow along on
the 3,600 plus videos
you'll see gradual, slow and steady,
improvement over the years.
So, that's my very first YouTube video.
Hopefully you guys got
some kind of inspiration
or at least a good laugh out of it.
I'm curious to hear from you guys
what is your YouTube story?
What do you remember
about your first video
compared to where you're at now?
Maybe that's only two videos ago
or maybe that's a hundred videos ago.
But talking about your
growth and your climb,
I think it could be
good to just get it out
but also serve as an inspiration to others
so that we're not just looking at us
compared to somebody else's middle or end
but going back to realize,
"Hey, everybody struggled at the start."
Everybody, kind of, sucked at the start
and got better slowly and slowly, slowly.
So, I'd love to hear your story.
Please share it in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Manjunath Shenoy,
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book Your One Word.
I hope you're enjoying it
and I really, really,
really appreciate it.
Thank you guys for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.